I thought we might close.
I have a question for you about your,
your derivation of these moral virtues
specifically from the enlightenment and
I'm curious about that because,
well,
first of all you could make a case that
it wasn't so much the enlightenment as
it was the specifically the rise of
empirical science and then you could of
course have a discussion about
how those two things are related.
But I'm also curious,
I've been reading Ian McGilchrist book,
the master and his emissary and Miguel.
Chris makes a pretty strong case.
I would say that yet the rationalistic
enlightenment values are in some sense a
consequence of the articulation of an
underlying set of principals that are more
metaphoric in nature,
more narrative in nature.
The case,
I also made it my book maps of meeting
and to some degree in 12 rules for life
that the enlightenment project,
and it's rationalities nested inside a
deeper web of metaphor and ritual and
damage that would be associated with
longer scale cognitive processes,
some of which are expressed
in religious thinking,
but some of which are grounded in not
so much rationality as in motivation and
emotion.
And I mean the way your
book is structured,
and I think the way enlightenment thinkers
think is that there was a miracle of
sorts that occurred sometime in the last
three to 500 years and people woke up
and became rational.
And then the question is to what degree
was the ground for that awakening
prepared by events that weren't the
awakening itself but that were associated
with other processes?
And I'm just curious as to
what your thoughts are on that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
there's nothing new under the sun and a,
I have good intellectual historian can
find the antecedents of any intellectual
movement didn't in various precursors.
Um,
you know,
it's hard to,
I,
I don't think there's a,
a lot in the enlightenment that
can specifically be attributed to,
um,
to uh,
uh,
religion,
particularly Christianity just based on
the fact that it was already around for
a thousand years and
nothing much happened.
So it couldn't be religion
itself or Christianity itself.
Although there are as,
as you say,
there are strands that were
carried over in particular.
And this is a,
I didn't cite that,
that I got from my other half,
Rebecca Goldstein,
my wife,
uh,
who,
you've appeared on stage.
One of it,
one thing that the
Greeks didn't have that,
uh,
the Christianity did,
was the idea of compassion
for the week and,
and universal human flourishing.
Uh,
you don't really have that
for all of the brilliance of,
uh,
of ancient Greece.
That wasn't a big feat.
But the enlightenment of course,
did not spring out of,
out of nowhere.
If I were to identify the antecedents,
what and why,
what happened prior to the 18th century
that allowed it to kind of pull down as
opposed to a couple of
hundred years earlier,
a couple of hundred years later,
one of them was the scientific
revolution conventionally located in the,
in the 17th century,
which not only provided a
paradigm for understanding,
namely,
uh,
testing propositions
against the empirical world,
seeking deeper,
naturalistic explanations for phenomena.
And which of course
overturned a millennia.
Old Dogmas reminding people that
bear their own common sense,
their own societies,
convictions.
Uh,
we're fallible.
So that was,
uh,
an essential precursor.
Another one was the discovery of the,
uh,
of the new world.
That there were entire civilizations,
entire world,
literally worlds in their sense that
that had been a unknown in that the
knowledge base that they have been part
of a Western civilization for Millennia
was radically incomplete.
And technologically,
I suspect that the,
the greater,
uh,
exchange of ideas and people,
was a contributor there prior to be
just prior to be lightened in the second
half of the 18th century.
There's a massive growth
in the efficiency of,
uh,
printing printing presses itself.
But it was the democratization
of books and pamphlets,
the rise literacy,
uh,
and the movement of people.
It became easier for,
uh,
for heretics and radicals to jump ship
and move to where things were cooler if
things got too uncomfortable
where they were.
And it's amazing how many of the
enlightenment thinkers were persecuted for
their beliefs.
They were threatened with
imprisonment or death.
Many of them ended up in,
in Holland or Paris or London or jumped
around to wherever they had made the
greatest freedom,
but also just the sheer,
uh,
I'll kind of precursor of the,
the web today.
The fact that pamphlet can be introduced
and within a few months it would be
translated into,
uh,
a dozen European languages and,
and smuggled in.
So the exchange of,
of ideas,
uh,
I think,
help to accelerate the,
uh,
the enlightenment.
Although since it only
happened once in human history,
we can never really know for
sure why it happened when it did,
but at those are three.
Good,
good.
Yes.
Well,
I mean,
we're in an interesting time now where
we can sit and make a video like this and
publish it almost instantaneously and
share it with half a million people.
I mean that that ability to share ideas
rapidly is developing a pace and God
only knows what the
consequence of that is.
We're,
we're in a situation now,
which was only occurred
to me about last year,
where the spoken word for the first time
in human history has the same reach and
longevity as the written word.
And it's easier for people to listen.
You know,
audio books are becoming very popular.
Lots and lots of people
listen to podcasts,
know I have working class people come
to my talks all the time and say,
look,
I'm sitting in my forklift for three
hours a day and I'm doing nothing but
listening to podcasts,
you know?
So that's,
that's a really remarkable thing.
So I think,
I think I'm going to let you go.
You've been very generous with your time.
I appreciate the conversation very much.
I'm going to close by
showing your book again and Steven
Pinker's new book enlightenment now,
which is tearing up the bestseller
charts and which is a guide to proper end
intelligent optimism in the 21st century.
And maybe I'd ask you just in closing,
what do you think there are
things that individuals,
what do you think individuals should be
particularly optimistic about right now?
And what do you think individuals could
do to spread the message that things are
getting better and that
we can solve our problems?
Yeah.
Um,
the fact that there are new efforts to
try transcend political divisions and
find out what works to
depoliticize and rationalize,
uh,
problems like poverty,
like climate change,
uh,
like,
like war and peace like crime.
Um,
those are very much worth supporting
that there are organizations like at a
political,
there are NGOs that tried to
monitor the state of the world.
There's effective altruism that just the
general application of rationality to
solve our problems that is responsible
for the progress that we've enjoyed in
the past.
And if there's going to be progress
ahead of us will be responsible for what
will enjoy in the future.
All right,
well,
I'm,
um,
would like to close to by mentioning to
everyone who's listening that you know,
things aren't getting better.
They're getting better because people are
facing problems and actually trying to
solve them.
They're doing micro
analysis of the problems,
breaking them down into
their constituent elements,
being humble enough to use
incremental solutions to solve them.
And to address them at,
at at a high level of resolution
instead of a low level of,
or a low resolution level
of ideological debate.
And it's really working.
And I would,
um,
what would we say encourage people to
pick up Dr Pinker's book because the world
is getting better and we should know
it and we should be happy about it.
And we should continue to foster that
development in every way that we can.
And I think this is an excellent,
this book is an excellent contribution
to that effort as well as your other
books like are,
are better rangers,
better,
better angels of our nature.
So thank you very much for spending the
time with me today and for talking with
me and it was a pleasure to meet you.
Thanks so much.
Thanks for having a Jordan.
Who's the pleasure was mine.